WEATHER TEAM IN LAS VEGAS 7
YEARS IN A ROW.
ONLY ON 8 NEWS NOW.
ALL RIGHT WELCOME BACK TO
OF A BETTER VENUE FOR A
HIP-HOP AND POETRY NIGHT IN
VEGAS THAN THE BROOKLYN BOWL
LITTLE NEW YORK ENERGY RIGHT.
YOU CAN CATCH ALL THE VIBES
TOMORROW AND EVENT PRODUCER
TELL US MORE ABOUT THE EVENT
WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
GREAT I'M BY THE TIME I LOVE
IT SO HOW DID THIS EVENT COME
TOGETHER. THIS IS A HIP-HOP
AND POETRY NIGHT FOR THE FOR
THE CULTURE FOR THE COMMUNITY
RIGHT SO I WANT TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT WAS LIKE A CURE
I WANT GO TOGETHER HAND IN
RIGHT TIME RIGHT AND I WAS THE
I WANTED TO BRING IT TOGETHER
WOULD LIKE A CURATED LIKE THE
PROFESSIONAL SO THIS IS WHAT
THEY DO YOU JUST LIKE OPEN
MIKE THAT IT BEFORE THIS IS A
CURATED LINEUP, DEFINITELY OK
SO THEN WHAT CAN PEOPLE EXPECT HEN AND WHERE IS THE
MAYBE TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
PERFORMERS ARE YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAVE A MIX OF HIP-HOP ACTS AND
SPOKEN WORD, ARTISTS ARTISTS
ARE COMING IN FROM OUT OF TOWN
PLACE LIKE ATLANTA FROM
CALIFORNIA AND SO I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO BRING IN SOME SOME
HASN'T SEEN BEFORE BUT THEN
ALSO BRINGING SOME LOCAL ACTS
AND JUST PUT EVERYBODY OVERALL
IN FRONT OF A BIGGER AUDIENCE.
SO WHAT'S THE AUDIENCE
EXPERIENCE LIKE.
TO DESCRIBE REALLY I'VE HAD
PEOPLE DESCRIBED TO ME AS I
COULD BE IN THAT THEY'RE THERE
FOR YOU TO EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
SOME OF THE SPOKEN WORD OR THE
LYRICS FROM THE HIP-HOP ACTS.
IT TOUCHES ON A DEEP LEVEL AND
SO I THINK PEOPLE REALLY
CONNECT WITH THAT AND SO HIP
HOP AND SPOKEN WORD IS LIKE 2
OF THE THINGS THAT BLENDS
TOGETHER REALLY WELL BEAUTIFUL
JUST CONNECTS WITH PEOPLE NOW
ARE ARE YOU YOU'RE AN ARTIST
AS WELL CRACK RIGHT HOW DOES
SOMEONE MAKE THIS INTO A
CAREER FOR THEMSELVES. I THINK
AS YOU WHEN YOU BEGIN WITH THE
SMALLER VENUES LIKE I DID AND
THEN YOU SEE HOW MUCH PEOPLE
GRAVITATE TO THEN YOU CAN
LEVEL AND SO BROOKLYN WAS A
BIG US AND WHAT I SAID THE
BIGGEST AND BEST SHOW TO DATE
NOW BECAUSE BROOKLYN WHAT A
BETTER PLACE YOU KNOW ON THE
STRIP AND WE'RE GETTING SO
MUCH EXPLOSION IS NEVER BEEN
THAT I'VE SEEN SPOKEN WORD AT
BROOKLYN BALL AND TO BRING
THOSE 2 TOGETHER IS REALLY
SOMETHING SPECIAL THERE'S A
LOT OF SUPPORT BEHIND IT AND
I'M JUST EXCITED FOR PEOPLE TO
KIDS ARE WATCHING BEING
INSPIRE YOU TO KEEP IT GOING
THAT SUCH A GIFT THE TOWN THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE SO WHERE CAN
PEOPLE CATTLE OBVIOUSLY THE
BROOKLYN BOWL RIGHT. BUT WHAT
TIME IS THE SHOW AND IT'S
THING.
SO ULTIMATELY I THINK I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS TO GO ON
SOMETHING LIKE A FESTIVAL YEAH
THAT KIND OF SCALE. THE
TICKETS ARE AVAILABLE RIGHT
NOW AT HIP-HOP AND POETRY DOT
COM. AND THE DOORS OPEN AT
07:00PM THE SHOW BEGINS AT 8
IN THE FIRST 400 PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY ARE IN THE BUILDING
ARE GOING TO RAFFLE TICKETS TO
OR A HOUSE THAT TO LINE AT THE
LINK SO IT'S GOING TO A LONG
LINE OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE EXCITED
TO GET INSIDE EXPERIENCE IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US. MY AND TOMORROW LIKE YOU